today's topic apparently big ed has
managed to get his hands on another
woman in a new series called 90 day
fiance so i'm gonna play the clip hey so
what do you think
the way he came out of nowhere like a
wild pokemon really [ __ ] me up
i did not see that coming hey so what do
you think
[Music]
hey man why does it why does big ed
remind me of the penguin from batman
and batman returns he has the same
little you know
hey what do you think it's just it's
cute
so um
hopefully i get to sleep here because
there's a sofa
i have a great surprise for you
oh yes
[Music]
look at that that looks fancy
our first glass of champagne together
so why don't you do a toast and i do a
toast i don't know that i'm toasting
i'll go first your sense of humor okay
get along trying to get along okay
that's good
cheers thanks for being a yes
liz and i are having a good time i think
we're both
reading the same signs and i'm going for
the kiss
god damn oh
if anyone has to verbalize that we're
getting the same sign after going for
the kiss
you know damn well that [ __ ] ain't got
gang that's crazy
someone was drinking champagne just
staring at me while they were doing it
i'd be super nervous
you imagine if i'm just over here
[Music]
oh this is super uncomfortable
but i'm more uncomfortable than most
people are you stupid
i'm more uncomfortable than most people
i guess but
stupid
oh man the water got into my pants it
was touching my
penis all right
that's worse that's more information
that we needed yeah
we don't need that kind of thing this is
one of the few times that i'm wet and
i'm just like what what happened
hey hey no
play the damn thing
cause i'm on a roll i'm on a roll
that's my plan oh damn so
you're here i am here so i did it
you did do it i did it right
um i'm just so nervous around you
it just took me a while to get used to
your your beautiful face
but um it took me a while to get used to
you
[Laughter]
no no no no no no no
oh god
no hey man i appreciate her she
she didn't lie she didn't lie no dude
no dude it took me a long time to get
used to your voluptuous body
well it took me a long time to get used
to
you god damn
yo you and that these are the signs that
you have to read
i still haven't forgotten how this man
was with rose
bern anyways um thank you for that
um for what i don't know thank you for
what
thank you for what i think he's just
taken he's just just taken the
the negative comment well what
how to ask you this it's just so crazy
but can i kiss you
don't make it weird
don't make it weird i won't
don't make it weird cue the villain
laughs
then he's tooched like a
in the very next breath don't make it
weird
oh man oh
man don't make it weird the [ __ ] starts
disrobing like
it was just interesting to transition
from don't make it weird to this man
immediately making i won't
i already told you i have a problem with
pda now this
was brutal b wow
it sounded like the mic was inside of
his throat i kept here
oh that was this [ __ ] was just too much
okay
wow
that was awesome
thank you
so that's out of the way now i can relax
now it can be normal no it will be
normal yeah
i'm not engaging that freak show ever
again and you know somewhere
like very far away in thailand or the
philippines
rose is just watching like [ __ ] i know
your pain
you you have to imagine that she's
watching this just chuckling
imagine who ends up kissing the first
thing that they say is
nah thankfully that was awesome
yes all right
she's enjoying this
she's not doing it all right thank you
for being in my life
i love it
[Music]
she it's okay she enjoys this game
okay now you just i've been waiting for
that kiss for two months
so that was amazing oh my god hey listen
listen listen i'm still afraid she's
engaging so
i mean it's not as awkward as we think
my awkwardness
really comes from i really don't like
pda i don't like that
i don't like to watch it let's watch to
see what she thinks still afraid i'm
still scared
of getting my heart broken but i'm
starting to feel something
from her which i never felt before left
or right what side do you like
technically you're supposed to be
closest to the door you're right
for protection i'm thinking this is
gonna lead to something
but if it doesn't work out
i'll be heartbroken sweet dreams
one more kiss
[Music]
too soon for that i'm just kidding
good night
[Laughter]
i love you too soon yeah i was just
kidding
you know what i'll come to big ed's
defense in this regard
it did seem like she was reciprocating i
think most of us have some biases
because the fact that we saw
it wasn't the other videos yeah and
we're not supposed to see that
yeah you know obviously there's money
involved in this so i'm sure there's
like some coaxing where people have to
do things
my discomfort really comes from the pda
i know and i know that
yeah and i know that but if we're being
honest like she's there for she's
probably there for the money he's there
because
he's got a good name that attracts
people you know anytime
i'm gonna give i'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt she's just trying
to see what's going on but
the i just it took me a long time to
took me a long time to get used to
you how do you feel about
i love you on the first date no
no no no no
there's not enough information for you
to love someone come on now
whatever everyone's at their own pace
this whole thing was just people said
this video and they wanted me to cringe
they succeeded and uh hey first date
no i don't care what pace you got i love
you on the first date
no no that's an automatical disqualifier
on the first date you ain't got no
information
hey pumpkin
peach peaches peaches peaches he tasted
like a peach last night
cheers shut up
[Music]
let it happen people behind closed doors
say cringey things to each other i'ma
just
allow it because i probably shouldn't be
watching this
i'm drinking coffee you're drinking some
green stuff matcha
how you feeling you're good good way to
fix my head
is it brushed uh i don't want it brushed
i want more of a natural just pull it
back
should we try the andrew bloom or you
imagine if she puts her hands through
her head
and just gets a clump of mayonnaise
bro i forgot about that
but thank you very much i guess what's
his name orlando bloom thing or no
no no last night was
off the charts um
we um we started snuggling
and we started to kiss and she is so
beautiful and soft and caring
she's a giver did you guys have sex
okay so yeah i mean we
we made love all night hey man i love it
i love it when dc comes out with new
comics where the penguin wins
this [ __ ] is amazing bro inspire
i like seeing a batman villain get his
good for him
that was great last night by the way yo
yo
yo listen listen listen i not okay
now i don't give a [ __ ] about closed
doors or no say it once
say [ __ ] once we get it move the [ __ ] on
okay but what if what if it was so great
you need to
remind the person no no no b
keep that [ __ ] to yourself we did it
about twice and
liz's body is amazing it's like a
surreal dream it's just like
and it was incredible like incredible
bro are you like [ __ ] certain you
weren't just dreaming then
like maybe the reason why you thought it
was like a dream is because like you
[ __ ] her in your dreams
yeah no all right barley
what do you do they don't interview her
ever it's just him
she don't get to talk i want to see her
side i never had anyone take over
and make love to me in my life it will
go down in big head history
as yeah as the event
so now i'm just hoping that every time
it's going to be like that
i mean
i wanted bun we do my bun it is a bun oh
it is
oh wow okay um how much more time you
need
um just a little bit put on lashes
finish my lipstick
[Music]
how was the rest of your night this is
really good
yeah it was a good night is he a good
kisser
i had to teach him how to kiss so
i feel like i have to train him to do a
lot of things but
we laughed about it this is kind of
inconvenient
she taught you uh-huh
see that's what i wanted to know i
wanted to see her side
because he's like yeah that was amazing
that was a thing
that was the this is like the alternate
universe where [ __ ] the penguin and
poison ivy start [ __ ] each other you
know like this is uh
this is quite interesting to watch this
is very interesting
i'm not gonna lie i didn't think i was
gonna like i thought i was gonna just be
getting being super creepy but by the
end of it i'm like
who's this lady and what is she about
yeah
i mean the mirror do you need more
lighting no i do my makeup like this all
the time
oh you do on the floor uh-huh oh really
i already told you you look good without
makeup
but but it's a wedding but it's a
wedding
it's a wedding i'm probably the first
person in history
to ever to be able to break out of the
friend zone and
now i want liz to be my girlfriend
it's nerve-wracking i'm nervous
uh so i might we'll talk about this now
how
um i think we're gonna look like a
couple
i would like to um
[Music]
i would like to introduce you um
as my girlfriend at the wedding
and so will you be my girlfriend
i was gonna say yes but yeah
no i think a lot of people are hating on
him because of how he looks but i mean i
think you could get past that
they're yeah they're good for them you
know i kind of want to see how this uh
this villain arc ends i love it i love i
love
villain movies and this is great so
that's my thoughts
anything else you want to add no i just
want to see the next
yeah yeah i think we all got to see this
but anyways that's it
if you guys enjoyed today's video leave
some comments below but i had no uh
crazy commentary seems like they're into
each other so
you know i'm not gonna just be mad at
him because of who he is so yeah
cool yeah everything maybe it was just
the way it was
edited that they would like you know try
to put some suspense on
the question and stuff like that but you
know yeah
all right well let us know what you guys
think in the comments below
[Music]
oh